لم تقدم وزارة الخارجية البريطانية
قدرًا كبيرًا من المعلومات
في هذا البيان الصحفي ، لكننا نعلم
أن أربعة من الأفراد الخمسة
المذكورين كانوا جزءًا من
إدارة الرئيس السابق
فيكتور يانوكوفيتش الذي كان مدعومًا من الكرملين والذي
أُجبر على الفرار  هذا البلد بعد
ثورة الميدان ، المرشح الوحيد
الذي لا يزال يسمع كييف الذي
يقترحون أنه سيكون رجل الكرملين ، إذا
جاز التعبير cnn ، اتصل به ، لقد
رفض بشكل أساسي هذا القول
إنه مواطن أوكراني وأنه في
الواقع يعاقب من قبل  الروس
لكن المثير هنا هو أن
هناك بعض التداخل بين
الأفراد المذكورين في هذا
البيان الصحفي من وزارة الخارجية
وأولئك الذين عوقبتهم وزارة الخزانة الأمريكية في
وقت سابق من
هذا الأسبوع ، أحد هؤلاء الأفراد في
كلتا القائمتين وكذلك
مسؤول أمني أمريكي قال  المعلومات
الواردة من وزارة الخارجية تتماشى مع
ما رأوه وكذلك ما
لا نعرفه على الرغم من ما هو ج  ontext
هو من هذا ، هل هذه المعلومات
الاستخباراتية القديمة هل هذا يعني
أن الروس يخططون لمحاولة
وضع هذا الشخص في السلطة بمعنى
أنه سيكون هناك غزو وشيك
أم أنهم يحاولون القيام بذلك بطريقة
أخرى  لا يزال هناك الكثير من الأسئلة
المحيطة بهذه المعلومات ، حيث
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم سعداء
لأن الناس يفهمون مستوى
التهديد الذي يتعاملون معه لأن
هذه المعلومات موجودة ،
وبالطبع ربما لا يكون مفاجئًا أن يتخذ الروس
نفيًا قويًا للغاية قائلين ذلك
هذه معلومات مضللة
ووصفها بأنها مزيفة